donkeys weren't always in such high
demand at this market near the regional
capital Cano last year one of these
creatures went for the equivalent of 50
euros today people pay more than twice
that amount new Huma Jackie says people
buy his donkey so quickly that he can't
keep up with demand
before we had truckloads full of donkeys
here but those days are long gone the
vendors say many of the donkeys here are
sold again through middlemen who shipped
the animals hides and bones to China to
the tune of 10 to 15 tonnes every month
Mao is a Chinese entrepreneur who won't
give his last name he's been coming to
Nigeria for many years he says he's not
personally involved in the donkey
exporting business but he's heard that
his compatriots back home can make
tenfold profits by selling donkey hides
donkey gelatin is one of our traditional
medicines it's good for women's skin it
makes them look younger and men like to
take it to improve their sexual
performance Lucia while local
businessman enjoy the unexpected profits
and Chinese consumers praise the effects
of the products the high demand of
donkeys is increasingly becoming a
problem in Nigeria especially the
question which exports are legal and
which ones are prohibited seems to
overstrain local authorities
this trade has long since been outlawed
because the number of donkeys in Nigeria
is dwindling but insiders say many
exporters find legal loopholes and pass
off the donkey hides as so-called
processed animal product a simple bribe
usually takes care of any lingering
questions posed by authorities even the
head of the regional customs office
admits the problem is out of his control
the average conservator is not very
knowledgeable is not knowledgeable in
dictating whether a process screen is
for donkey or is for horse or is for cow
a new shipment of donkeys has just
arrived new who my Jackie says they're
clearly worse for wear after being
transported 100 kilometers from the
border region near new jam he's not the
only one who worries that one day there
may not be any donkeys left in northern
Nigeria